okay why don't we hit this up because i
think um
i don't know if you guys are following
the story or not but i want to hit this
up and kai i don't know if you have the
video or not if you don't it's all good
it's totally fine
we can just pull up the picture so we
can talk about what happened here so
uh and if you can go to my uh twitter
profile
as well just to show what happens so for
those of you that don't know
for those of you that don't know naveed
afghani
is a wrestler in iran a national
champion if you can pull up his picture
so we know what he looks like
he's a national champion and iran
wrestler two years ago he decides to
protest
against what was going on iran with 200
other people and his two brothers
okay so he goes out there and he
protests and
you know the economy in iran's not doing
very well
it's challenging times of course there's
the sanctions that u.s has put so these
guys are having a hard time and he goes
up against the prime minister says we
need to do
something in iran because this is not
going the right direction
long story short he ends up getting
arrested because he is a national
champion he's a figurehead people know
who he is he gets arrested
they take him in they go and
they put oil in his uh not oil alcohol
in his nose for him to admit that he
killed somebody
so eventually to stop from being
tortured he says what
fine i did it okay they announced
just two weeks ago they're gonna execute
this guy iran announced that they're
gonna execute him and kill him right
there's three brothers they decide to
execute him but the world's like
maybe they're not gonna do it he's gonna
get 74 whiplashes and then get executed
his other brother is going to get 74
whiplashes and go to jail for
52 years or 54 years his other brother
is gonna get 74 lashes on his back and
go to jail for
27 years okay this is what the charges
were against these three brothers
for simply protesting right i go out
there on twitter if you can post my
twitter a tweet that i put up and here's
what i said on twitter i made a video
about it go up go up go up go up go up
a little bit higher you're almost there
you're almost there right there
so i go up and i said posit deposit and
i said
those who live in a country with human
rights rarely think about it
and those who don't can't stop thinking
about it iran hasn't valued human rights
for over 40 years
if you agree with this please retweet
and tag olympics let's save the life of
navidad
my message here was directed to the
olympics the reason why i was directed
to the olympics was because
olympics can do something about this to
say if you do
and move forward with this execution
guess what we are going to
cancel iran competing in the olympics so
i announced this then if you go up there
to a cnn article to see what the
olympics said just type in naf nafeed
afghani navid afghani in a search
go to search and type in navidad type
right there cnn it just came up cnn
first one
go on the second article go on the
second article and let's read this
together
iranian champion wrestling navidafari
executed despite the international
campaign so he was executed
a couple days ago if you can make it a
little bit smaller kai so i can read it
to the audience right there
so the international olympic committee
said it was shocked by the announcement
in letters thomas bach the ioc president
had made direct personal appeals to the
supreme leader
and to the president of iran this week
and asked for mercy
for navid afghari while respecting the
sovereignty
of the islamic republic of iran the
statement said it is deeply
upsetting that the pleas of athletes
from around the world and all the behind
the scenes work of the ioc together with
the noc of iran
united world wrestling and national iran
wrestling federation
did not achieve our goal fine so you
went and you played so i said tag
olympics
we tagged the olympics on instagram
facebook and twitter maybe 10 000 times
i said okay so they make this statement
they reached out to iran iran doesn't
listen to what the olympics say
say screw you we're going to execute him
even though you like this or not
mother comes out if you watch your
mother's speech you will be heartbroken
if you listen to what the mother says
now
here's a couple stats for people that
are watching this
iran is the number two country in the
world for executions
last year was 253 people were executed
this is not the death penalty by the way
this is execution there's a big
difference between execution and death
penalty execution is
uh what do you call a german type of
execution you know
and death penalty is a different kind of
death penalty you go up there you do
obviously there's a form of execution
but you go through execution
out of the 253 people that were executed
13 of them were
live in person let me say this one more
time
in iran 253 people were executed
13 of them were live people came and saw
a person being executed in the streets
in the street
it's it's a statement if you do this
this is what's going to happen to you
they're the number two country in the
world in execution number one
china you know who's a no more country
in the world china's number one
china is number one iran's number two so
then i said okay
let me pull up the list of what
countries have been banned from the
olympics kai can you pull up the history
of countries that have been banned
from the olympics this is the step we
have olympic countries banned from the
olympics the banning of the russian
athletes
team real olympics not the first time a
teamwork country has been banned from
participating in the olympics here's a
timeline of countries that have been
banned
1920 antwerp five countries were banned
due to the environment the first world
war austria bulgaria turkey hungary and
germany find paris
in 1924 the ban of germany following
world war ii makes sense through
though austria bulgaria turkey hungary
were allowed to compete
1948 london german and japan were barred
for their participation in the second
world war
fine so germany and japan were barred
1964 tokyo south africa was banned by
the ioc for taking part due to its
oppressive uh uh uh uh how do you
pronounce that word apatite
regime which say that apartheid which is
apartheid is what like
you know it's segregation it's another
nation blacks and whites the whole
segregation exactly so they were famous
in south africa and by the way
year after year after year after year so
68 72 this goes on with
south africa you can keep going lower
and lower so south africa has been bound
by the way 1968 north korea competed
against second
nfo in 1966 which meant they were
suspended by the ioc causing the nation
to miss 1968 olympics
as well so 1968 mexico north korea
couldn't compete
1978 uh 1972 munich south africa
as well as zimbabwe was banned from
participant as other african countries
threatened pull out
if rodeza took part okay 1976 montreal
south africa south africa south africa
2000 sydney afghanistan was banned from
the olympics due to its discrimination
against women under taliban rule as well
as its prohibition
of sports of any kind and then you have
obviously 2016. many russian competitors
were banned following revelations of
state
sponsored doping all athletes were not
okay okay see all this stuff right
okay so let's come to today okay
olympics
you pleaded for an athlete to
not be executed and iran didn't listen
now what are you gonna do are you not
gonna say fine
you are banned from the next olympics so
now when you say that
some people say well that's not fair
because you are
making people's dreams not become a
reality in iran that are trained so hard
to go become
a olympic winner here's one thing you
have to realize i have an age i have an
agent that works for us his name is
morteza alborzi okay
phenomenal guy i met this guy when i was
23 years old he's a sweetheart of a guy
he's doing very well for himself and
in our company right now morteza albersi
out of l.a is a eight or a nine degree
black belt can you type in morteza
alborzi black belt morteza
alborzi black belt morteza spell it for
us too kai
zee a you got it actually perfect so far
he spells better farsi than english by
the way so al borsig a-l-b-o-r right
there came up right
amortez alborzi black belt yeah okay
perfect
press that and then go to images okay
this guy's been all over the place when
it comes down to martial arts okay right
here right there
no you had it right just go on that
magazine that says masters go on the
magazine that says masters if you go
back that's him
alborzi okay eight degree nine degree
black belt
he was in jail in iran he's been one of
the top
olympic trainers and the judge not
judges but somebody that trained the
iranian team for the longest time right
he escaped he came to america he trained
here he trained a lot of students here
tens of thousands of students in beverly
hills have taken his classes
this kid this man has built so many
young boys that became leaders
moral of the story is this if the
olympics
are so serious about this movement why
don't you ban iran
and china of 20 the next olympics that
we have why don't we okay well i'll ask
you this question because you're sure
wouldn't wouldn't the regime in iran
right now look at a ban from the ioc
similar to a public execution like they
don't give a damn about promoting sports
in iran they just want to suppress their
people
stay in power so that would almost
strengthen them a little bit to say
we're still going to do what we do and
execute people if we
perceive that you commit these crimes
they might embrace that because they
don't really care oh i don't think
that's how this works though
let me tell you how this works uh tom
how much longer are you going to
tolerate california mistreating you
at what level no but at what level is a
breaking point for you
by the way i'm not this has got nothing
to do with our relationship whatever's
asking you right whatever the answer is
it's out there all right it exists okay
but but could california push you to a
breaking point of you saying you're
leaving
um yes okay i guess anything's possible
did that happen to me
could they push me out he left colombia
his family left mexico right i mean how
come how come we have 40 million
immigrants in the u.s
how come people are leaving other
countries i think iran
thinks their people won't do anything
about it and they have to understand
this whole sanction that trump put on
iran why did he put the sanctions on
iran
strengthen saudi arabia okay why else
did he put the sanctions of iran
because it's evil maybe as a method of
saying hey and then he supported the
revolution
of the people wanting to protest against
iran right to for what for maybe a fall
of an empire in iran that is not
believing in human rights not taking
care of its people they're claiming what
they're doing the people are afraid
they're oppressed
i mean you're trying to get people to
have some kind of a freedom this would
be a certain statement that's being made
to say look we don't support
you know execution we don't support what
you're doing because you're doing that
look forget about the olympics
but i agree with you i think that's what
they should do but would it have any
effect
on the leadership in iran i i don't
think so couldn't there be a coup
isn't there this a country where that
could actually happen i couldn't see it
happening really in north korea
and some of these other places but don't
they have the ability there
to cover i mean with the support of the
u.s with the support of saudi arabia
to flip this eventually or is it too
difficult to flip what
the leadership in iran to get rid of
these of course you could do it i mean
of course you could do it it's not uh
how is that done
how is it done it's painful and it's
going to cost a lot of people's lives
and it's going to be a lot of young
lives this is why
it's not the younger generation that
doesn't want a revolution it's the older
generation that's telling their kids be
careful
don't go out there which i fully support
every parent will tell their kids that
but the opposition you know when you
look at when you talk to a lot of when
you beat a lot of persians you'll hear a
lot of people say things like this in
l.a
they'll say you know i don't i don't
know why it is man when i meet persians
man persons are
such good business people they're always
making money it's not that they're
making such good money
it's the fact that the business people
of iran left iran to come over here
it's not that they are the business
people of iran left iran it's not that
all persian people are business people
do you understand why it's that they
left iran
to come over here the business people
that left iran it's a filtering process
that you have the capitalists left yeah
look i got kids man i'd love to when
they take my kids to iran and quite
frankly two years ago i was gonna go on
a
trip to iran with a few friends and you
know not publicize it just to go
to iran because i missed my country i
was born and i wanted to go to the
streets i was raised all this other
stuff
but uh for me to go to iran today would
not be the smartest move to make to go
to iran today
there's a chance you would they'd be
waiting for you they would be waiting
for somebody
i would love to set an example with a
guy like you they would love nothing
more than that but i would love one day
to go there with a group of friends and
say hey here's what it looks like
it's a beautiful country man the history
of it is so beautiful to go to it but
i i you know heartbroken when i saw that
navidafkari was executed it's
unbelievable
how about his brothers iranians would
love to see a coup
a big part 50 uh no it's a bigger that
it's a big
bigger than 50 questions but but here's
the thing at the only reason why that
number could change
is what quest one question at what cost
a hundred percent 95 would love to see a
coup
but at what cost then the cost is only
twenty percent or ten percent or five
percent would like to see you cool
with the cost i don't this makes sense
or not it's like you know someone i'm
saying like
what percentage of the world would like
to be a millionaire
well everybody of course but what
percentage is willing to work 80 hours a
week for 10 years
well not a big problem so it's at what
cost
am i willing to do we have any case
examples of coups
um initiated by the people obviously we
can't look at iraq
us came in they're invaded them right or
we can't look at libya you know
type of thing what coups have been
successful over the last 50 well i mean
a revolution flipped iran
40 something years ago 40 years ago so
since then the perfect example they have
the playbook for it in iran
kai you were you trying to say something
yeah we can't hear you here's the mic
a lot of the eastern european bloc had
revolutions when they broke when they
broke up from russia you're saying
yeah or the uss arab spring
is another one yeah popping out sure
it's good
just recent 10 years ago oh yeah look at
libya i mean look at these countries
gaddafi um were you surprised they
actually went through with the execution
to me personally i was a little bit
surprised
well um here's did you see what trump
tweeted yesterday about iran
type in uh trump tweets and go to see
what he said about iran yesterday
middle of the night by the way i don't
know if you saw that or not did you guys
see that or no
have you seen what trump tweeted okay so
this is two days after the execution
go up a little bit to make sure it's not
okay you're good it's not that one keep
going keep going keep going
this is what trump just said about iran
okay right there right there right there
right there click on that one right
there okay
click on it so we can read the whole
thing just yet according to press
reports iran may be planning an
assassination or other attack against
the united states in retaliation for the
killing of terrorist leader soleimani
which was carried out for his planning a
future attack murdering u.s troops and
the death and suffering
caused over so many years any attack by
iran in any form against the united
states will be met with an attack on
iran that will be
one thousand times greater in magnitude
right okay
that happens two days after the the
execution of navidad okay so you asked
the question
uh were you surprised because you were
surprised uh
i'm not surprised adam asked the
question yesterday which was a very good
question
uh you said something about don't you
know don't you think iran
is trying to make a statement to say hey
man you keep bullying us and publicize
us
we're going to show you in a different
way trump tweeted please do
not execute this again okay thanks trump
so you're saying trump tweeted please do
not execute and they did so i'm just
saying they're not going to listen to
trump
guys i'm seven years old looking outside
my window fourth grade in the fourth
floor in iran on gilbane hojet and i'm
seeing
thousands of people marching down the
street flagellating their backs you know
what flagellating is yes self whipping
themselves
but it's peeling the skin off your back
so it's leaving a trail of blood
and they're screaming mad bad umbrical
death upon america
the the the messaging of what the media
says to the iranian people about america
if you live in iran america is the
worst most evil empire in the world
if you live in iran it's their method of
preventing their citizens to leave to
come to iran come to us
because propaganda all propaganda north
korea north korea iran
if you had a michael jackson shirt on in
the 80s you were the coolest cat on
campus
i'm telling you right and iran if you
had a michael jackson shirt on that was
like
if you were a calvin klein or tommy
hilfiger shirt
you're the coolest guy on campus if
you've got a tommy you'll figure it out
sure
so yes i would i think majority of iran
would like to see it i just don't know
if it's gonna
i'll say this you know they didn't
listen to trump's plea he beg i mean hey
please do i mean he was very respectful
in that tweet where he asked them not to
execute the wrestler
i don't think they're gonna look at that
as bluster i think they believe
after four years he pretty much backs up
what he says
so right i mean a lot of times people
think of what trump's doing he's you
know a maniac with tweets or whatnot but
if they did something don't you believe
that a thousand times might be accurate
as far as what the retaliation would be
i mean don't you think the uh iranian
leadership might hate trump
um but don't think do you think they
respect him a little bit that that might
be true and they better
do you think he's kept him under his
thumb a little bit out of fear yeah so
my
my guesstimation is the following when
they retaliated after soleimani was
killed do you remember what iran did
do you remember what they attacked
a military base that was empty
right okay if you remember that they
attacked an empty military base to say
look what we did if you come after
soleimani right and then they said
we're not going to attack but the guy in
the iranian the military i think is a
foreign minister i don't know which one
it is
by the way can you type in around four
minutes that's a genius if you've never
seen this guy's interview you got this
is this is a strategist this is not a
lightweight guy
if you're talking let me see if it's if
it's uh go to images to see uh go to
images david sarif
go to images yes this guy's legit
yeah this guy is a a he is
if you've ever seen any of his
interviews he's not a lightweight
okay he's not a lightweight can i tell
you something about this yeah who's my
favorite guy on cnn that i was like i
love this guy i love this guy cnn
yes he does a show every sunday brainiac
brainiac this guy comes on the show
quite often
an iranian foreign minister comes on the
show quite often
if you did not know all the issues that
the united states has with iran
he is very convincing he's very
convincing very convincing he did an
interview on cnn he's very convincing
and he is very strategic so my my uh
my guess is the following if they do
attack
do you think trump is dead serious about
the counter attack to iran
yeah you ask me yes i do that i do do
you think he's that serious about how
ugly it's going to be for iran yes or no
frankly yes i do
do do you do you say yes he is for his
bluster however with iran i think he's
very paying very close attention to them
if iran attacks a military base and one
soldier dies do you think trump will
retaliate i agree yeah do you think the
exchange will be one soldier for one
soldier do you think it's gonna be a
thousand seconds he will make a point
perfect yeah i think they won't do
anything
until there's a different president
that's a little softer of course
and easier going to be able to make an
attack like that that's what i think
you're wrong yeah because look what did
what did iran do the day uh jimmy carter
was no longer president what did they do
the day reagan
became a president what do they do what
did he back off i'm sure
they released the prisoners you remember
the releasing the prisoners and reagan
gave the speech giving credit to carter
and same thing but
what iran realizes carter's not gonna
attack us
i thought ben affleck did that yeah ben
affleck did that argo carter won't
attack us
but uh reagan will so you know there is
a part of uh
trump and reagan that they have some
similarities but where is iran
on the nuclear proliferation at this
point with everything that happened with
the iran nuclear deal and obama giving
him a boatload of cash and then trump
pulling out
and then they said that they're going to
start the nuclear proliferation again
where are they
they got this one country i don't know
if you've heard of called china that's
given them 400 billion
dollars and china just doubled their
nuclear uh uh uh powers that they had in
china they doubled it
not a little bit they doubled it they're
spending money into it and if they're
befriending north korea and they're
befriending iran it tells you who
china's allies allies are
and it also you know the new access of
you well and then the dynamic of the u.s
supporting saudi arabia
like we are you know troops financial
support
right there to keep iran in line so far
so good
yeah i uh um i i don't know i
i um again i'd love to see nothing more
than to see iran be free again
and maybe i'll be doing some interviews
on that topic here pretty soon
you